the Georgia grand jury looking into  whether Donald Trump and his cronies may  have committed crimes those are criminal  crimes just to be very very clear has  completed its work and sometime in the  next likely few weeks we will maybe find  out whether Trump is getting indicted in  Georgia now it's important to remember  this is separate from what's going on in  Washington DC where the January 6  committee made a criminal referral of  Donald Trump to the doj multiple places  where Trump could end up indicted  sometime in the next month will it  happen or not let me know in the  comments and make sure you're subscribed  to my YouTube channel youtube.com the  davidpackman show where we will have  full analysis of what would it be like  if Trump indeed did get indicted